how is your current relationship with  God that's an intense question I don't  know I think it's good I think there's  more that I could be doing I was reading  the Bible more a year ago and then since  my sleep schedule kind of went off track  I stopped waking up as early and then I  stopped reading the Bible in the morning  so I should work on that because I did  feel better reading the Bible more seems  weird I know to all you people who  aren't Christian that sounds strange it  was strange to me too it's still strange  to me I don't know how it works exactly  but it makes me feel better I'm trying  to go with the flow so if things don't  work out that I want to work out I'm  thinking well maybe that's not meant to  be maybe God doesn't want that for me so  I've been trying to operate like that  and it's been good for me I think  because I like to exert a level of  control over everything that isn't good  for me or the things around me and so  I've let that go a little bit